bonjour je suis je vous assure la plus
gentil des femmes je suis cool je suis
simple sûr et là je suis soumis en ça
soit sauf sauf quand je suis en plein et
quand je suis en colère je voulais avoir
envie de temps que le coût de quelqu'un
d'être des femmes
quand on est en colère mais complexe
mais on peut dire que c'est parce un des
assesseurs
je veux me conter une histoire
personnelle il ya une trentaine d'années
que j'étais réformatrice en relation du
monde et elle je dépendais de l'agrément
que je devais tout mon échelle année
gros demander chaque année à une
administration
donc ma carrière des bonnets de ça et
j'ai une très bonne contre l'idée de
contester modalités d'évaluation des
étudiants
mon agrément a été refusé j'accueille
chômage
j'étais vraiment défini c'était déjà
trop en faire ça et donc pour moi
c'était le vide c'était ma prime comme
air et en même temps geste de violence
et j'étais vraiment les reds aux blues
de finir et donc j'ai mis la main sur
mon téléphone
perdu pour perdu j'aurais très bien le
tout le monde
et je suis loin de mon téléphone et je
vous dis pas parce que j'ai fait sur les
biens revenant cédric la colère peut
entraîner cette agressivité cette
violence mais comme deux essais je peux
expliquer je te dire un truc avec ma
place à l'été odieuse avec moi kevin
laisser je me we justifier et à ce
moment là j'aurais très envié meadowbank
c'est klinsmann le malade sous les
sapins de claire j'aurais très envie de
tendre nova j'agis je vais bien sûr je
vise à briser l'élan vie qu il serait et
s'ils me disent n ont jamais laissés par
les goûts si vous aviez des monnaies je
trouve ce double raymond et
potentiellement ma colère est bonne en
ciel brumeux violences en tout cas au
moins bons mots je pourrais devenir
épouvantable et bien que je crois que
nous pourrions vraiment changé le monde
change et le violence donc tout faire
diminuer bien entendu en une génération
si non vraiment de l'enfance et si nous
considérions l'éducation avec notre
regard
alors que là vous voilà
j'imagine que vous aussi vous avez des
souvenirs d'en france adepte des
contrats
élimination de la justice était grave
que ça y est je vous jouez un instant de
d'une vie d'un enfant
voilà je suis le dic fille j'ai l'épaule
et ne surtout pas pour maintenant
aujourd'hui joue pas comme moi j'ai pas
le temps de bien apprendre la leçon il
ya un pas dans ce sens discuter et ça va
être beau et j'ai pu me concentrer je
suis pas bien là et tout d'un coup elle
avait 13 soit normal je suis des anisés
je suis démoralisé il devrait y songer
j'aimerai m'acheter des pages je le sais
je suis chine et à ce moment-là la
sentence tourner car ge sacralisé maman
me disent c'est bien parce que j'ai
envie d'un câlin j'ai envie qu'elle mais
coûte cher et qu'elle me rassure jean
lesquels nos consoles elle est fatiguée
n'allons là tu me dis qu'on travaille à
tout le temps et puis je peux vous savez
la balle ronde il est sévère pas parce
que je réussisse à l'épaule c'est
difficile alors je suis là tu vois la
fronti très revient à les jolies pour
les jeunes mariés dimanche que tu vas me
revois à pékin soit raisonnable que tu
vas laisser un temps son petit frère je
vais me calmer
avec un jeu de vidéo mes copains du
monde immonde foisonnent et pendant ce
temps là je suis tranquille et à ce
moment là maman qu'il est fatigué qu'il
l'ait dit des choses tout à l'heure
comme ça tu sois pris le nez les jouets
des jeux vidéos des fonds je suis dans
les temps et je sais plus et la violence
contre maman et j'avais de bons c'est
aussi je t'aime
serait ce comme la route est ce que ce
n'est pas ce que vivent bien des enfants
c'est un peu caricaturé mais quand même
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pour cette
danse il sait pas exactement la même
chose que pour moi avec maintenant
représentants de mon administration là
sauf que l'enfant lui ne peut qu elle ce
n'est pas qu'il ne le faudrait pas
l'enfant ne peut pas se calmer son
cerveau est immature les neurosciences
le prouve aujourd'hui ne savez pas vous
raconte qu' il y a un tout à fait nos
mails d'hormones et je veux pas rentrer
là dedans parce que je ne suis pas face
à ce fait l'objet d'une autre conférence
mais vraiment ce n'est pas été surmontée
l'enfant ne peut se calmer
l'enfant peut manifester l'enfant peut
exploser
nous pouvons dire ne pouvant justifier
l'enfant que juste exprimer et une fois
les faits ce qui donne donc dire un
enfant calme toi c'est une absurdité
c'est un non sens surtout sur les 10 et
me dire tu es chanter village de la
balance
c'est une injustice
parce que l'enfant pour une fois a
tellement besoin d'amour
il a tellement besoin d'être avec qu' il
ferait tout pour être bien avec avec sa
famille ses parents à l'école avec
développe intégral mais quand tu n'y
arrives pas encore une fois lui n'a pas
la possibilité de mettre en mots et de
justifier je suis en colère parce que et
même si l'on osé le faire
est ce que on n'accepterait qu'il le
fasse
donc vraiment je pense que l'enfant
l'éducation c'est la base de la
possibilité d diminue cette agressivité
cette violence je suis vraiment contre
les punitions
je suis contre et reproche je suis
contre les exclusions et je suis contre
et classement à la compétition toute
chose que vivent des enfants très très
souvent la punition obtient dans le pire
des cas ce qu'elle vise la soumission
est ce qu'on a envie de créer deux fils
adultes souligne pascal avait l'habitude
d'être soumis se soumettra à la trappe à
louis
il sera bien dans l'hérault ou alors il
faudra qu'ils explosent pour se libérer
je veux dire ici que je suis contre la
compétition le classe des classements à
l'école était terrain pourquoi parce que
il n'ya qu'une première place et que ça
fait plein d'autres déçus ça fait plein
d'autres en difficulté et puis enfin
quand la collaboration la coopération
dont on parle tant
c'est justement la base une réussite
commune et que justement on est aussi
dans la possibilité je ne sais pas vous
mais moi quand je vous ne trompe je ne
jamais les jeunes commencent et j'essaie
de réussir
mécontent quand un enfant se trompent
et bien si on le sanctionne le
sanctionner durement et moi j'avais à
dire quand on se plante on pousse je
suis aussi je me disais qu'on nous
reproche à la scène un reproche
critiquer ça c'est à dire tu mais est ce
que c'est vraiment utile
allez je me pose la question
imaginez imaginez que votre partenaire
vous disais tu sais pas l'amour une
chose sur un million la meilleure chose
[Applaudissements]
que j'ai vu contre l'exclusion et
l'exclusion c'est un non sens vraiment
ce qu'ils risquent de de provoquer le
plus de violences l'être humain
le petit être humain n est pas
collaborer être fier de réussir avec
être fier d'avoir participé
ils veulent aider l'économie tout à
l'entraînement collectif
si on ne le fait pas de place dans ce
groupe humain et pour l'exclu on a la
paix on explique le gnr qu'est ce que
c'est une fausse bonne résolution du
problème parce qu'avec des bombes à
retardement
lorsque pour exister dans ce monde qui
nous a jetés il n'y a qu'une seule
manière de venir au lieu d'être
être dans la construction c'est la
destruction
c'est l'image grasse et la construction
l'industrie faut donc vraiment
l'exclusion est à mon avis une solution
vraiment tellement une fosse est
tellement dangereux leçon que je ne
prenne vraiment l'inclusion au contraire
je trouve eu une éducation bienveillante
alors qu'est ce que c'est que
l'éducation bienveillante on en a fait
beaucoup de beaucoup de sens on est
peut-être liée au sida bienveillante
parce qu'on a souvent confondu avec la
mollesse avec de la gentillesse
non la bienveillance c'est plein de
puissance
c'est plein de force et la même solidité
ça peut aller chercher un enfant est
rappelons le solliciter à l'étoile et
liens parce que tu as en vaut la peine
salle d'audience la bienveillance
protège évidemment la bienveillance va
s'occuper d'eux mais aussi la
bienveillance à mon avis la gym de
bienveillant apprend aux enfants à
s'exprimer
je me disais tout à l'heure que l'enfant
ne sais pas il a poussé son petit frère
mais justement vous dire cet enfant
visiblement qui était très en colère
tout c'est mon petit frère c'est
dangereux et c'est interdit c'est
dangereux ça peut lui faire mal c'est
dangereux donc c'est à peine si
y avoir des mois je suis très en colère
j'ai besoin de gamme et là je t'aiderai
a trouvé le col dont tu as besoin parce
que c'est légitime aussi ont des besoins
développement d'une gamme donc ce que je
propose c'est qu'on apprenne à l'enfant
à s'exprimer qu'on lui donne une
solution plutôt que de lui interdire et
de lui et de le mettre dans une punition
garde donc vraiment des gens
bienveillants à la chorale enfants à
s'exprimer
un adulte bienveillant aussi selon moi
apprendre à l'enfant à réfléchir régime
pourquoi tout le monde ne pas être
ensuite un bon petit soldat qui va obéir
à toutes les injonctions de l'umq se
profile aussi sophie dessus ces
injonctions qui ne va prendre de la
distance et qui va vous analysez les les
salles des réseaux sociaux avec nous à
être tout c'est de toutes ces contre
vérités toutes ces absurdités qu'il
brille qu'ils partent comme san andres
dans l'espace et que on peut tout
récupérer en faisant revivre jeu léché
tout ça c'est bien dit que et 1% va donc
attendre réfléchir ça me paraît comme
instrument à distance et c'est pour ça
que les matières et tant de plaisir
notre conviction de cette association
celle saloir ensemble qui promeut des
ateliers de philosophie avec les enfants
pour les enfants dans les rigoles on en
fait des petits philosophes à 50 80 des
enfants qui sont capables de dire
des choses vraiment magnifique je ne
profondeur de réflexion extraordinaire
quand on les laisse parler et quand on
forme leur esprit bible je pense aussi
qu'on ait bienveillant doit apprendre à
l'enfant à s'exprimer et à considérer
l'autre donc pas comme un ennemi mais
comme quelqu'un qui peut avoir une
opinion différente et je selon lou entre
l'altérité pour moi c'est le même
engouement que je connaisse à l'autre
dès lors qu'il existe visage de l'autre
non plus et je disais levinas vraiment
l'autre il existe il est sacré comme le
châtain et pour discuter sans se
discuter me semble aussi la mission
d'apprentissage des adultes donc
respecter ça ça et ça m'aide aussi
évidemment la possibilité de comprendre
la l'empathie comprendre la bleue
l'idée de l'autre qu'est-ce que je
penserais si j'étais à sa place
pourquoi dit il ça ça ne changeait
d'être d'accord avec lui mais je peux
comprendre qu'une pause différemment de
moi
selon son contexte et paiera donc tout
ça c'est de la communication sans
violence ça nous amène à vraiment
communiquer et pas à s'opposer et ça
donne vraiment des possibilités d'être
une rénovation sans violence où chacun
va pouvoir parler de son désir de son
point de vue mais sans vouloir forcément
écrasé celui de l'autre je vais vous
dire ce que j'ai fait vous avez la
direction du service
sera-t-il clavel refusé mon âme
allemands le lendemain j'ai remis la
main sur téléphone allô j'en ai rêvé
vient te voir demain prévu
mais elle m'a bien sûr et donc j'y suis
allé et d'empathie
j'imagine que tu as une responsabilité
bien sûr étudiants n'étaient pas sûrs de
la qualité de ma formation donc dans cet
homme c'est normal tu me refuse
également mais je voudrais te faire une
proposition et tu viennes à
l'humanisation avec moi comme ça je
crois te rendre compte et la souris
l'homme discutait pas en travers de g1
voudrait mon agrément
j'ai continué ma dernière c'est ce qui
m'a donné le plaisir notre l'argent
[Applaudissements]